use la ley asociativa de la adición para
escribir la expresión 77 + 23 de una
manera diferente siempre que ambas
expresiones para mostrar que ambas dan
los mismos resultados está la ya
asociativa de la suma que suena muy
elegante y complicada simplemente
significa que podemos sumar estos
elementos en diferente orden si tenemos
por ejemplo acá el 77 más 23 estos
paréntesis me van a indicar que primero
tengo que resolver lo que se encuentra
aquí dentro de ellos y después continuar
con lo que se encuentra afuera por
ejemplo resuelvo esto de aquí 77 2 679 y
una vez que resolví de esto hago la suma
con lo que queda afuera que es más 3
y esto nos va a dar 82 ahora usando la
ley asociativa que nos dice que el orden
no importa 77 más 3 y eso lo vamos a
asociar de manera diferente por lo que
igual vamos a poner aquí el más 2 no
vamos a poner paréntesis resolvemos esto
el 77 más 3
va a ser igual a 80 a esto le sumó el 2
y me va a quedar como resultado 82 la
ley asociativa nos dice que puedo poner
los paréntesis también así puedo poner
otra cantidad bueno en estas mismas
cantidades 77 más 32 pero ahora los
paréntesis los voy a poner acá
de manera que voy a tener tres más dos
esto va a ser 55 más 77 el resultado de
nuevo bases 82 así que no importa como
asociamos los números el resultado
siempre va a ser el mismo